I have the distinct pleasure of having
professor fil sundew from the business
school at Harvard talking to us about
leadership and management my dad is a
surgeon my brother is a hospital manager
every night at home growing up I would
essentially be in the middle of these
conversations between a surgeon
resisting the managers and the hospital
manager trying to convince the surgeon
look these matters and I tell you why so
it's a it's a craftsman it has always
fascinated me that cetera for at a
personal level the reason why I'm so
intrigued by trying to find a way for
surgeons and hospital managers to
communicate and work together in the
interest of the patients and the whole
organization at a higher level I really
think that it's important to understand
ways in which managers can really
improve firm performance and to
improving firm performance have an
impact on the growth of the economy so I
really think that now we have all the
tools to establish this link between the
micro level what happens you you know in
the context of a firm and what happens
in the context of a country it's very
important to understand that the
internal communication within these
organizations and really understanding
what is the common objective there is
going to be the key to improve
performance for for each individual
Hospital but I feel like this is
relative stuff
you